we rarely start an hour with an
offseason exertion but I think the
Eagles require a little extra time right
this is a tough team to figure out right
they they won the Super Bowl and shocked
everyone with Nick falls at quarterback
then last year they were sluggish they
were bad yeah overlooked their awesome
games they had no business losing got
fire yeah and they gave the Saints
everything they could handle right in
the divisional round and now we just
kind of like we're kind of like numb to
the Eagles again I don't know we but I
feel like there's this sense that you
know when we list the potentially great
teams for 2019 a lot of people aren't
considering that the Eagles have every
reason to believe that one of the great
teams I think it I think the hesitation
comes from the chronic injury issues
that have been experienced by Carson
Wentz I I think you're exactly right
right right there everybody just kind of
sweeps them under the rug cuz they go oh
well we don't know about him yet so
they're not like truly on our Superbowl
radar they should be at least in my
opinion hey two things right off the bat
with the Philadelphia Eagles first of
all Doug Peterson's a hell of a coach
he's extremely aggressive so on a weekly
basis he's consistent about putting
pressure on teams Jim Schwartz the
defensive coordinator he's kind of the
same way so you know from the coaching
standpoint they pressure you right off
the bat then you get into the talent and
the team that how heroes have been
billed and you started to go damn I mean
gosh this team has got it all really
there's only one area on the team that I
look at that I go dude this maybe not
quite up to par and that's the
linebacker position but everything else
you know I always start with upfront and
I go gosh you know getting a guy like
andre Dillard in the in the first-round
tackle out of Washington State is a
phenomenal football player for me was in
the conversation as being one of the the
best old linemen in the draft he could
play tackle might be able to play guard
right away this year but as you know
Mike as that we all know who follow
football that the games are one up front
and the Eagles still got a lot of big
bad dudes on both sides of the ball
added to the fact you add a guy like
Malik Jackson to replace a Michael
Bennett which I thought was really good
but you know Michael Bennett's getting
up there in years Malik Jackson still
kind of more in the prime of his career
and the other thing is - Sean Jackson
one of the issues they had last year was
somebody that could stretch the defense
down the field getting a guy like DeSean
Jackson will only help
you know people like Al Shan Jeffrey and
the rest of the receivers are sorry some
of the underneath and intermediate
routes that Zach Ertz runs and everybody
else I have a lot of faith in what the
Eagles have put together by way of an
organization with Howie Roseman
acquiring a talent Doug Peterson but
remember what a surprise he was as a
coaching hire and there were some people
who said he'll be horrible he'd be the
first one to be fired I mean the Eagles
don't make those changes lightly and
after Chip Kelly emotional intelligence
was the buzzword for the Eagles and they
found a guy who I think is very good at
connecting with his players and they're
very good at identifying their
weaknesses and addressing them
I still think what's hovering over the
team is this question of how long Carson
Wentz can stay healthy will he be any
different when will he even be ready to
go remember we had Doug Peterson earlier
this week some sound from him not
compressing right some hesitation about
the possibility that that Wentz would be
ready for OTAs when we just all assumed
he'd be fine and good to go but that's a
real issue
I like the return of the Shawn Jackson
yeah I'd love to see LeSean McCoy come
back at some point you know and this is
a team that I mean if I'm an Eagles fan
I kind of you know I like where they're
viewed right now because you're not the
team that everyone's talking about so
the bar isn't unreasonably high and you
also can get a little chip on your
shoulder that hey man nobody's noticing
right if we won the Super Bowl two year
ago and last year we had a damn good
shot everything whether they're driving
the game-winning score I mean the ball
went throughout Sean Jeffrey's hands I
believe he was running the route he was
on the 20-yard line when the ball went
through both of his hands and popped in
the air and interception ever I called I
who did I was I was ultimately wrong
yeah and I went out on a limb and said
the Eagles are gonna be the same you did
and they they had a lot of opportunities
I mean that game really you know was
going the Eagles way and then Sean
Payton had the guts to call the fake
punt right and that changed everything I
mean that was the changing of the game
right there they went on a long drive
got a feel though that kind of changed
the whole dynamic from there on out but
the Eagles are fearless they're
battle-tested
they have true belief you're right the
Carson one situation is certainly the
biggest question hey Brandon Brooks they
lost him in that Saints playoff game
he's one of the best guards in football
he tore his Achilles tendon I believe
that's gonna be a shame because he's not
gonna be ready to go
100% to start the year but even you know
we question what are they gonna do it
running back oh you know what they do
that how heroes man again you know one
of the GM's in football that would say
again that is playing chess why the rest
of the everybody else is playing
checkers they make a move to get Jordan
Howard then they draft a mile sander at
a Penn State who I'm sure they knew
really well because they're in the state
of Pennsylvania along with him and I
like both of those editions running back
needed to be upgraded I thought those
were smart moves as well especially
because I think last year and and you've
made this point time and again as
relates to Carson Wentz they get away
from their offense yes scheme right and
their preferred strategy because they
get so enamored by what once can do yeah
and if you can't run the ball the whole
RPO the big fat from two years ago you
can't pull off the P right if the r
isn't there you've got to have a
legitimate run threat or they will just
sit back yes and wait for you to throw
the ball you've got to scare them with
what your running backs are gonna do and
last year they were not able to scare
anybody with what their running backs
could do no they could not find that
formula of oh we're gonna dominate the
line of scrimmage like we did the year
before and force your hand that way then
to open up the pass game they did not
get that going last year you know hey
some of the magic that they had from the
2017 Super Bowl year you know between
being able to run the football losing
some games late in moments where we just
went wow you know that never happened
the year before you know blew some
opportunities you know on the road to
the Tennessee Titans right get blown out
in New Orleans there were just a few
things that went on through the year
where we just went ooh wait I thought
this team was good and then you
scratched your head and went what the
hell is going on and by the time they
got healthy and now all the sudden
Carson Wentz gets knocked out Nick Foles
takes over
they got healthy at the right time to
make that run and make the push for the
NFC playoffs when you look at their
draft picks yeah there's there's the
glaring omission of a third round or
because of the Golden Tate trade right
you know I
we've praised the organization but that
was a big Mis yeah I guess he ultimately
didn't do anything for that team huh
relative even close to what a
third-round pick would justify and they
could have done a lot of things with
that third-round pick this year and it's
just gone for their half season with
Golden Tate that never became anything
close to what they needed
and and you know but yeah it did not
work out the experiment was not good
I'll be the first one to tell you - I
thought it was a good move at the time
so I did - yeah I mean I really did but
as I started to watch I want my golden
tastes definitely lost the step he's not
as explosive as he once was and yet he
couldn't quite find his little niche in
that Eagles offense and yeah they lose a
third-round pick and that's things
certainly I was also shocked at the
Giants paid Golden Tate so much money on
the free agent market but you know when
all said and done you think the Eagles
are a Phillipi off football team I think
I think they're the division champs you
think the division champs you think
they're gonna be like number one number
two seed type of thing I think that's I
think that's the kind of they're gonna
have if Carson Wentz can stay healthy
yeah you know I said this yesterday if
I'm an Eagles fan I am very nervous
about it every week every day I'm gonna
exhale deeply after every game where
Carson Wentz is able to walk off the
field and isn't injured in some way and
I'm gonna get more and more nervous as
the season goes on because we have seen
it two years in a row now in December
all of a sudden you get the torn ACL
done last year the back problems done
yeah and this year who do you have faith
in no that's Nick Nick Foles I go there
a Todd Feld know Thurston Howell who's
gonna come in and play yeah Thurston
Howell you're funny
ya know you're right they just made a
move what and got Cody Kessler right so
okay that that'll fix no none of it and
I'm just saying that's obviously they're
they're a little concerned about that
aspect - III hear you there and I think
that's a legitimate question Carson
Wentz has to chill out you know again he
just gotta chill out you can't fight for
every foot on the football field all the
time it's okay sometimes just go down
and take the sack you don't have to
stand in the middle of the mosh pit and
break seven tackles to get a two yard
gain it's just not worth it as the
starting quarterback of a franchise at
times there it's more important for you
to be on the field and I'm hoping that
he's learned some of these lessons I
think that the decision to sign Cody
Kessler yeah and to waive AJ Perez the
aaf phenom who I believe played for the
Birmingham iron but I short-lived a yeah
I think that is an implicit
acknowledgement by the Eagles that
Carson Wentz isn't gonna be ready for
OTAs because they wanted to upgrade who
would be there to distribute it yeah
sure let's let's just roll the dice on a
project guy right
we got to bring in somebody who's got
riparians who can who can carry the load
because it's sun felled and it's it's
kessler and we're dealing with the
rookie clayton forsen AKA thirst and how
right and i think i think that's our
indication that we're not gonna see once
in OTS yeah that that that is enough for
me to say combine that with what
peterson said yesterday we're not seeing
it but yeah i don't know if i'll go that
far but certainly it at least shows me
that there's worry or maybe they want to
take they got them on a rep count or
they're gonna they're gonna limit some
of the you know periods of practice that
he's allowed to partake in but you know
again i just look at this Philadelphia
Eagle team I think they are a Superbowl
caliber football team I really do you
know their offense their defensive line
you know we forgot about the injuries
that kind of rolled up on this team last
year you know whether it was you know
Darren Sproles or Ronald Darby and you
know you just go kind of through all the
positions Jason Peters was in and out of
the lineup you know they had a lot of
issues across the board Derek Barnett
their first-round pick from two years
ago he was hurt so I think at full
strength and if they can stay healthy
this is still one of the better rosters
in football and one of the more physical
rosters info Derek Barnett made the play
that put him in the Super Bowl exactly I
mean it was the the the winter sack no
no no to put him in it no it was Brandon
Graham in the tsubaki I wrote him in it
was four times seven Vikings are driving
and he he blasts past a tight end and
rips the ball out of case caddos 2107
and that's it right alright um projected
win total yeah according to the folks in
Vegas nine and a half for the
Philadelphia Eagles are you over or
under I'm gonna go over over yeah I'm
gonna go over to I think the Kevin would
you go over at ten and a half mmm I'm
probably not I don't think I'd bet money
I do want to say they're like a ten and
six and eleven and five football team
but I think if you had to go oh Chris
you got a bet a thousand dollars on this
ten and a half I would go no I'll go
under there I'm gonna say 10 and 16 I
think 11 and 5 the Cowboys are gonna be
good in this division so they're gonna
have to deal with that I just look at
the NFC every time we think the Cowboys
are gonna be I know this is some high
level analytics next-gen stuff every
time we think they're gonna be good
they're not I hear you I know but you
know I don't know I just feel like I
have a hard time thinking of that Ross
they have is not gonna challenge the
Eagles to the east I just I look at the
Cowboys a lot like I look at the Eagles
and go damn I don't see a lot of weak
spots on this roster to have any concern
in any one area there's a way the
Cowboys can handle the contractual
business over the next few months that
would make me feel like they can maybe
not have the distractions of guys
worrying about getting paid we'll see if
they do that yeah okay and and it's not
just dak Prescott it's is he q le yeah
sure they got to get him to write her
off even though that that's not a big
big do
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports